man i'm gonna tell you guys one of the
craziest rejection stories i've ever had
i'm talking about such a big l to this
day it's scarred me
so my younger years i was doing my thing
went to the gym the girl behind the
teller uh
i was like
what you laughing because you told me
about this [ __ ] no she's laughing [ __ ]
i asked for her number right
and she gives it to me i'm like cool
friday this is giving you mine it's
tuesday when i get her number my friend
will only go out after you during the
shift she said quick
so we texting during the week and on
thursday she stops responding but i'm
like we already agreed to friday so it's
all good i'm saying young boys gonna
show up to the gym all right
i show up to the gym yo stop laughing
yo stop laughing [ __ ]
why are you laughing at my pain
yo yo yo get up here and be respectful
all right get up here and be respectful
no it's not because you're laughing in
the back
go ahead that's what happens so friday
comes right and i'm sure
[Music]
so i show up there friday night for
closing shift right
and i'm waiting for her to come off her
shift i wait outside very respectful to
want to show up at a workplace you know
cool i'll text i'm like yeah i'm outside
we're good to go
i see the doors open and out she comes
with another man
[Music]
this guy's like six six
big old white dude right
and i see a tad cab pull up
i'm staring i'm maybe like 50 feet away
i'm like standing at the edge just
outside of the light you know because it
was nighttime you know they had a little
lamppost and i was standing in the
darkness
[Music]
and just as i think they're about to see
me
i look to my right and i see some bushes
and i jump inside the bushes
[Music]
i'm hiding in these bushes
waiting to hear this cat pull up
[Music]
the cav starts going
and then it circles around it comes
right in front of the bushes
i hear the
i hear the window get pulled down
and then i hear a voice gay
hey we know you're in there
[Music]